there are a few principles that I
mentioned as moved constructing this
graph that useful for all graphs not
just column and bar graphs I'm the
principles I want you to be able to
remember them so I already unfrozen this
I think is probably the image that I
want you to have in your mind that i
will call center have the principles
right so you know this like Pele is
there a peel poster ready it's I don't
see one actually is a bit unusual the
customer banana on the side of the roof
anyway um did he appear like paragraphs
of our coding I want you to think of
salt for grabs okay now you may either
jot some of this down don't worry about
be exhaustive but get some milk for
description um does your graph have soft
on it these are like the four major
point so you can see I've mentioned all
of them except for one there's one I'm
missing um these are like the principles
that no matter what graph you're doing
you want to have a really obvious and
clear scale that's what chosen axes that
are marked out everything's labeled
clearly and this is the one that I'm
missing I'm the title over the top of it
so and what is the type of this graph
routine entry yeah it's our proportions
of food right so I've got a bit of space
just here because this of course I think
it's a food consumption may not food
creation like the farmer you like that
so that kind of makes a difference as to
what this graph is about so let me
explain it in a little more detail um
what do we mean by one of the things
we're looking for with regard to scale
well we already showed remember we're
drawing these guys here we want the
scales to the accurate you have to
choose them right you remember we chose
our up to 35 when people see percentage
on something a lot of them a lot of
people put 100 as the top number that's
not a very good choice of scale right so
choose carefully and then this is
something that will guide which is like
horizontal which one's vertical we
talked about this all the way back in
linear relationships which is not on
this independent it's the one you can
choose freely which is the one that's
dependent well what this number will be
what value it is depends on whatever
your
the pivot variables okay so figure out
the scale don't worry too much about
getting this in depth okay just trust me
apart from that when you think about the
axes there are a few specific things to
them we already talked about scale
please make sure it's obvious make sure
that even this is one they're really
important things out colombard apps
actually got so much to say about Krista
ground these things here you want to use
a ruler for these don't stand a chance
or use the lines that are on your actual
piece of paper that's fine and this is a
really important one we're going to talk
about misleading graphs later today okay
one of the things that makes a graph
misleading is if the vertical axis
doesn't start at zero if it starts some
really high value one okay what kinds of
things need to be labeled when you have
a look at the axes we talked about this
just for protein and percentage don't
just tell me what that access refers to
tell me what you knew it is is it ours
or is it minutes is if degrees this one
degree is that okay if you struggle to
remember to label your axes then just
picture this and hopefully it will be
like wow that's that's pretty terrible
cheesy but anyway that's that will stay
with you okay last one um and I said
this is the mint that most people often
forget but actually if you're creating
graphs not just it mounts but my foot
life taking a title tell me what are
these things of that a graph should be
able to stand by itself and not require
bits of extra stuff do they was going a
lot more person to tell you what is it
should be it's only thing that's
communicated so is your salty now I did
point out I didn't want you to spend too
much time light of all these details
it's probably good if it was some down
because you remember things better if
you do write them but you can take this
and you can
behind your walk because I didn't
actually make it but um this is a nice
clean version it's got all of the
details down there and stick it in if
it's nice and poppies for you I'm not a
replacement but as I possess something
looked at